ce devait être un nouvel espoir pour les
civils ukrainien une fois encore les
armes résonne à marioupol contrairement
aux annonces de l'armée russe qui
promettait un cessez le feu écoutez le
compte rendu de l'envoyé spécial de
france télévisions dans la ville luc
lacroix
ici à marioupol c'est un tonnerre de feu
un déluge de feu qui s'abat sur la ville
et plus particulièrement sur le site
d'asos talent derniers bastions
ukrainien où il y aurait encore des
civils dans ce quartier regarder tout a
été détruit les façades tiennent encore
à peine debout elles sont calcinés et
pourtant il ya encore des habitants qui
vivent qui survivent ici les bombes
passe au dessus de leur tête pour aller
jusqu'au site d'azf talent ils ont tout
perdu leurs appartements sont détruits
vivent dans des caves certains ont aussi
perdu des proches mais ils nous disent
que partir d'ici de l'endroit où ils
verront vécue serait un drame
supplémentaire